c'est
tout
ch oui
non non
alors qu'est-ce que c'est une épave ouais ils
ne le sont pas ce n'est pas un parking est-ce qu'ils
les amènent ici et ensuite ils leur enlèvent des pièces
après qu'ils ont été détruits, ils ont l'air
oh ouais d'accord ils vendent
des pièces ça a l'air vraiment  orgue puis après
ils sont ouais puis après qu'ils soient
démontés, ils euh ils écrasent le reste d'entre eux
je vois ok ça a l'air bien organisé
ouais et on ne voit pas de vieilles
voitures oh j'en vois une qui s'est
écrasée sur le dessus de  là ouais, il y en a eu
un là-bas, il a tué environ cinq
personnes, où est celui-là, il était sur
cette
colline, mais ils les amènent tous ici pour les
démonter et vendre des pièces, c'est un parc de
recyclage plutôt qu'une
décharge,
d'accord, dans ce coin là-bas, à
notre  13h00 ouais je vois bien 11h00 ouais
ouais ouais il y a un vrai M ouais il y a
vraiment frappé ce vieux pick-up et cette
autre voiture juste à côté il y
a un train qui arrive en
arrière-plan un train froid
ok
tourne autour du moteur  dans le
train froid pendant que nous sommes ici
ouais, il y a une mine de charbon par ici non,
ils sont hors du Wyoming, ok,
arrêtons, ok, allons